Here is the new way to do copywriting in
2026. Okay, I want you to stop chasing
clients entirely. Build your own
business. Be your own client. Here's
exactly what you need to do. First, you
need to pick a niche that is profitable
and passionate. One, something you're
super passionate about that people spend
money in. For me, I may do something
like golf or fiction novels. Those are
two passions of mine. People spend a lot
of money on those things. Next, pick a
social media platform that you can write
a lot of long- form content solving
problems for people in that niche. So,
if I go with the golf example, I may
create YouTube videos or a Substack
account where I help people hit the ball
longer, hit the ball straighter, things
like that. Post content every single
day, three to five times a day, short
form content, maybe one to two pieces of
long form content. And in everything
that you post, add a lead magnet to it.
Something valuable, something useful
that they will give you their email in
exchange for that lead magnet. Once they
join your email list, send them one
email every day of a highly entertaining
story that makes them feel good about
reading your content and teaches them a
little something. And then at the bottom
of that email, plug your product, which
I recommend a paid newsletter or a paid
community. I run a paid community for
copywriters to help build a clientless
business like this. I launched it a
couple months ago. I have 60 members in
there paying me $50 a month. By the end
of the year, we'll likely hit 200 to
250. At 200 members paying you $50 a
month, that's 10 grand a month, a
six-figure income, which takes the same
exact amount of work and effort as it
would have taken to go get clients,
manage those clients, deliver for those
clients, retain those clients as it
would just building your own business
that you completely own is way more
profitable and grows over time. So
listen again.